d'argenteuil bobines donnant rendez vous
parle pas des mêmes choses dont je parle
de la province mois
michel drucker animateur de radio et de
télévision
dany saval madame michel drucker
comédienne
aujourd'hui ils font découvrir aux
téléspectateurs de 30 millions d'amis le
monde me cages des animaux familiers
qu'est ce que c'est que cet échalas mais
qu'est ce que c'est si je devais laisser
sur ton tas de cailloux un chat de luxe
d'un des symboles le lévrier sont en
général de chiens distant leleu vrille
effectivement éteint chez distant mais
c'est un chien qui est très attaché à
une seule personne c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que nous avons chacun notre c'est un
chien qui s'attache à un seul mètre et
qui lui est complètement dévoué et qui
qui est aimable avec les gens mais sans
plus c'est à dire que quelqu'un qui ne
connaît pas valve qui valent caresser le
lévrier vava ce nécessaire et va se
détourner très rapidement quand je
tournais avec michel simon
il avait l'habitude d'avoir avec lui une
petite gazelle du désert qui est à peu
près de la même taille que ces chiens là
qui demandait à table à manger comme un
chien enfin quitter tout à fait adorable
et j'avais envie d'avoir une gazelle
comme la sienne
impossible de trouver une petite gazelle
quelle est la capture et je voulais
surtout pas qu'on capture une gazelle
pour moi alors en désespoir de cause un
jour une amie m'a dit mais tu sais j'ai
rencontré un jour un chien c'est
exactement comme une gazelle est en
effet à l'époque c'est cette race de
chien là était très très peu connu il y
en avait peut-être une centaine en
france donc je suis allée voir une dame
qui avait une chienne comme ça et je
mets tout de suite acheté son chien non
à l endroit toujours un missile grâce à
chaque déjeuner alors dû casser
voilà yamina vient faire ton doudou
basque et mina on est toujours sur la
table aussi ou même ligne pour ce faire
un bisou les attendent toujours qu'on
ait débarrasser la table qui puis
d'assiette pour venir m'embrasser
je la préférais de 3
on a chacun notre préféré ça c'est la
préférée de massy c'est mina et puis
celles qui étaient sur la table la
première c'est lily qui est ma préférée
à moi évidemment zaza n'appartient qu'à
michel l'écouter quand j'ai rencontré
daniel avait déjà une petite chaîne i
pod et perrine riverains bac qui
travaillent avec moi télévision nous a
offert je dois à la vérité de dire qui
la veut faire admis cette chienne et je
m'en suis emparé là pour se faire
pardonner un jour en faisant un portage
du côté de salles où il est passé devant
un élevage de but est et il l'a il a
acheté un petit budget qui est donc mina
et puis à l'entrée tout pourtant me
disant tu vois je t'ai pris ta chienne
mais voilà je te donne je t'ordonne un
autre j'étais contente j'élève ma petite
nina qui était tellement mignonne que
c'est ma fille qui a décidé de me
l'apprendre je me suis retrouvé à
nouveau son chien j'étais triste j'ai
fini ni deux j'ai dit ça va tu vas me
faire des petits ce moment-là ça n'était
assez grande
j'ai marié hasard qui m'a fait cet petit
chien et j'en ai gardé un qui est enfin
machine alors pourquoi nous avons 3 wii
fait
l'allemagne
mais je dis toujours un rigolant que
dany est malade elle a contacté le virus
à quelques années de la grippe et ip but
elle est passionnée par les chiens et
par ces chiens là
emma contaminé moi j'avais un setter
quand j'étais plus jeune et plus un
cocker et puis je me fais découvrir ces
chiens qui sont très étranges et qu'il
est difficile de comprendre quand on vit
pas avec eux et puis j'ai eu le coup de
foudre
mais ça prend des proportions parfois
inquiétant que ça veut dire que je suis
pas certain de garder mon calme comme je
regarde maintenant si un jour je
rentrais ya un quatrième chez à la
maison parce que j'aurais beaucoup de
mal à mon âge à m'habituer à dormir dans
le panier parce que les gens que les
trois chiens sans son autre lit quand
ils portent tous les matins et tous les
soirs je sais pas comment je vais bien a
banni les déchoir
en réalité je crois que je crois une
réelle premier jour
seraient ils me tueraient
non
nada j'ai tout de suite bien répondu
bob n'est pas couché
et couche toi
m
c'est moi qui les élève il n'ya que zac
j'ai eu du mal à élever parce que michel
à la dose prise très tôt ce qui fait
qu'elle n'obéit d'abord qu'elle lui ou
pratiquement et comme il est fou d'elle
et lui passent tous ses caprices
ce qui veut dire que moi je n'ai aucune
prise sur elle alors les deux autres
lily et mina qui sont là devant elles
sont très très obéissants parce qu'elles
sont élevées entièrement par mois je les
ai toujours avec moi et elles
comprennent absolument tout ce que je
leur demande et tout ce que je leur dis
ça avec eux un chien surtout comme c'est
un chien comme celui-là ça occupe une
place aussi importante qu'un cana du
ltte fait partie de la famille avec des
amis nous avons stéphanie et trois
autres filles est maintenant un petit
chat considère qu on a aussi nos enfants
kada zina
trois ont pris les faits portent pas une
contrainte de viol et calais non
justement j'aimerais tellement pouvoir
faire comprendre aux gens que qui me
disent souvent ça que les animaux sont
les aiment suffisamment il faut avoir
disons six mois de patience avec
seulement six mois de patience et
ensuite vous n'avez plus aucune
contrainte que de thés votre plus beau
souvenir avec mon plus beau souvenir
mais peut-être seller c'est leur
affection
j'ai pas un souvenir particulier sont
formidables tout le temps tous les jours
ce sont mes amis ce sont mes enfants je
les traite comme tels ils font ce qu'ils
veulent à la maison j'ai pas de souvenir
particulier je dis assez constant c'est
chaque jour millions d'avis aujourd'hui
avec tous les bistrotiers rutte avec
pierre le à leur leader bernard bros luc
bernard essor pujol je remercie tous
ceux qui sont venus applaudir chantal de
ma merci